we were talking about this earlier in
the week the idea that he knows from
being at practice
a little bit about how patrick mahomes
moves decision making although i think
it's still inherently unpredictable i
don't think the guy ever does the same
thing twice so i don't know how much
tendency or tell there is in being on
the same field as patrick holmes but
there is at least a little value in
being around the guy and knowing how he
plays how he prepares how he performs
yes there is uh to the point you know
body language right just anything like
that you know there are go-to moves for
quarterbacks for what they do right well
oh man the pocket's collapsing i'm gonna
give the old okey doke and go like lean
like this way and then go that way right
there are tells that way which could
help them but like as far as the offense
is concerned man defense ends don't know
that crap they don't know anything like
they're not like oh andy reed when they
make this check of the line of scrimmage
coach they're going to do this and that
no it'd be different if it was a safety
or a middle linebacker all right if it
was something like that that would be a
guy that would be more in tune to
schematics what the quarterback's doing
at the line of scrimmage calls signals
things he's heard at defense end he's
gonna know his right tackle that's
blocking him and know all the nuances of
him and then maybe have a little
advantage in the mahomes and his
movements i have a dumb question yeah
and this might be the fact that i spend
too much time with mike florio because
it's very much a mike florio like dumb
tape i love it i love it how you have
quickly pivoted so excited to uh a slam
against me okay well it's it's not the
dumb take like i'm not trending on
twitter dumb take but just uh one of
those mike fleurs this is a classic mike
florio yeah do you think that d ford
knowing that his last game with the
kansas city chiefs here it is he
famously was offsides
he's now in the super bowl the
spotlight's on he's playing his old team
it's going to be brought up do you think
that that slows him down even a fraction
of a second on super bowl sunday that's
a great mike florio take
you know that as much as you try to
insult
the fact that that is such a part of how
he's viewed and who he is right and what
happened last year on a huge platform
it's an even bigger platform now
i don't know maybe it doesn't yeah
you're like tomorrow and now i'm gonna
hear it on friday too because of you now
it literally just popped in my head and
i was like that is something mike florio
would think and say so i just beat you
to it but it is it's a human emotion
like well it's real yeah well i'll say
this i bet you he's very careful about
crowding the line of scrimmage he'll be
very aware of that all game long because
of what happened last year where he's
not going to try to take up every inch
to feel like he can get the advantage
let's go next level
we talk about what d ford may know about
patrick mahomes there's a chance patrick
mahomes knows what it takes to get d4 to
flinch
and maybe the cadence or the movement
there's no doubt a little subtlety here
or there to get him to jump i like it
while we're on this we did find
something because
no joke here's where i thought he was
going though let me just say this i
thought you were going to say something
like he
jumped off side on purpose no no no no
no no don't come back it was a mike
florio take not a part of my take but
it's cool we've gone down this road i
think that's gonna be a big part of the
football game though is mahomes snap
count and we saw mahomes in both playoff
games he's really become a master of it
yeah it's aaron rodgers it is you know
the way he can either go quick or his
hard count is real and this is a game
you know as we've talked about a lot
like hey robert salas telling those
front four like we can't win this game
unless you get to my homes right so he
knows they're going to be like ready to
go and i you got to play the snap count
game early on just to back them off and
take some of that aggression and
explosiveness away it really is a
bizarre sort of a stew that gets
concocted when the three of us are
together i mean you know it really might
be some may say i'm the chef i'll say
that but but but between the the way we
think the personalities and the
approaches i think we tripped over
something that's actually pretty good
yeah it did yes it did he's very he's
like you're like his young son yeah i
just well no that's my my co-host
i'm his uh nephew but it is these are
the human emotions of the game i mean
like i said in the last segment i'm not
watching tape i'm not you know checking
x's but the human emotions you watch it
right it's something that i i study and
you figure it out and there absolutely
is something there to patrick mahomes
knowing d ford and vice versa and how
that will play out on super bowl sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports